tomorrow Chase Jilla model Devonta Smith
I'll remember everyone who's in front of
me bro we're in a line it's the quarter
season Carnival men are you
are you uh coach that's the funnel cake
stand don't matter
oh I compete I'll take the biggest prize
ever uh looks like you haven't quite
earned it yet gotta win a few more games
still what about him
[Music]
I have no ball pits today maybe next
week maybe not go ahead write her
obituary see if I care guys where are
you going it's all patched up good as
new try your hand at trubisky ball are
you gonna play
you still have a baby voice
not yet what but that creep one the
Browns gets rewarded
that elf just gotta hold them off now
I'm chilling hurts and you can like me
and still hate Philadelphia nah I need
to see more this year there's a lot of
pressure but it's because everyone
believes in me I can hang up where's our
defense what can I get for all these
something quite special
they just never give us running backs
what we deserve
you want to split water do you want your
own
I know what that means but I love this
kid's motor
oh yeah he's got that dog in him